Okay.
I need two volunteers here at the beginning.
While we're waiting for everybody else to come in.
You have to come up here and do something
one up.
Okay.
So each of you actually,
I don't want to people that are sitting together.
So Lucas,
you enjoy your stay,
but yeah.
Rick,
why don't you come up here?
Come here.
So your job is to grind.
This is a spice.
So you grind it up good.
And then we're going to take it back and show it to the people around.
You are going to smell it.
Okay?
See if you can,
you have to really grind it like this.
Look.
Okay.
So we got two spices here that we need to identify.
Okay?
You can go back and grind them at your seat and then show it to your neighbors
later on.
I'm going to ask you whether you know what it is.
[inaudible].
Okay.
So here's how we're going through the history of organic chemistry and the
development of the molecular model.
So generation by generation.
And last time we got up to the students of Calculi,
uh,
who actually did experiments to allow people to figure out something about
structure,
not only what was connected to what that's constitution,
remember the nature and the sequence of bonds.
So we had composition,
what elements are there,
what ratio they're in,
how many atoms,
right?
Then constitution,
the nature of sequence and bonds.
And now we're going to see if you can go beyond that without cheating and using
ex-ray diffraction to figure out how things are arranged in space.
So structure and we talked last time about coroners proof,
uh,
positions in benzene and his proof that all the positions in benzine were
equivalent to one another.
And today we're going to go really to the next generation.
Kerner wasn't all that much younger than he was,
at least halfway in the generation there.
But van Hoff is a full generation beyond.
So we've got to look at him.
It says under him tetrahedron,
and it says down here tetrahedral carbon.
And also,
uh,
we'll see,
something about Albert Loddon Borg and about your,
uh,
whatever.
Great,
great chemical grandfather,
Peter Kohler at uh,
Harvard.
Okay.
So as we were closing last time,
we were looking at this definite picture of the arrangement of atoms in space
where the models are clearly real models held together by rubber and their
tetrahedral.
And it explains why there can be three isomers of dye substituted a symmetrical,
he die,
substituted,
um,
ethane.
Of course it was wrong.
Do you know why it was wrong?
Why they're not three different bottles?
Yeah,
because you can rotate about the middle bond freely.
It's not frozen in one rotation here or is it?
We'll see something about that later on that turns out to be what's called con
formation.
Remember,
that's the one of the C's,
but now we're in configuration how things are attached to the tetrahedron.
Okay.
So after Paterno had published that he got a letter from his former sponsor who
had moved on adult Lieben,
uh,
Austrian,
who was at this time in Italy,
first in,
uh,
first in Palermo.
And then at this time I think he was,
he was in northern Italy,
I think in Pisa.
Oh Torino,
it says up at the top,
Torino 25th to June,
1869 and you can see a translation there if you click.
But anyhow,
it says permit me deer,
my deer and Manuel,
I they corresponded like several of these people who are great friends where for
a very long time,
uh,
permit me to make an observation regarding the isomerism pointed out by you.
And by Cannizzaro it's a little bit of a misleading to say by Cannizzaro.
He was very cautious about this as you know,
but he introduced the paper between and he shows those two structures here which
looked like type structures with those brackets.
And you can see what's fastened on the two carbons is h two HDCL and HCL hcl.
But he wrote the CLS differently obviously meaning to denote this difference in
phase of rotation.
Certainly it's not absurd.
This kind of a isomerism even without any differences among the four valence as
of carbon.
Remember one could have been straight one crooked and short and long or
something like that.
Uh,
I believe however,
that I don't earlier when I suppose that the same cause which keeps me from
accepting it will also keep all the other chemists from doing so in a silent
agreement with one another.
You perhaps haven't thought that in this kind of,
I saw Marisela crosses the Rubicon which separates speculation.
That's considered legitimate about the mode of combination of Adams from
speculation,
which is less legitimate about the position of the atoms in space.
And notice here that he added as an afterthought Vedo the true position to the
atoms in space rather than just chemical position.
Right.
In all speculations that had been made up to this time,
people have always been careful never to let enter in either the relative
positions in space,
distances and and surroundings of the Adams.
This idea doesn't even enter into the speculations of Calculi about isomerism in
the aromatic series,
so he draws the picture of the hexagon and numbers one to six.
Yeah,
calculate believes that chlorine one chlorine to positions is different from
chlorine one three and from one four because in the first case,
the two carbon chlorine is find themselves combined with one another.
But in the second case they're separated by ch and then the third case they're
separated by two [inaudible] and two except this one has no need to make
hypotheses about the surroundings of the atoms.
That's really weird,
isn't it?
He says in one case they're connected to one another.
Another case,
there's a ch in between and in another case there are two ch is in between,
but to talk about this,
you don't have to talk about the surroundings of the atoms.
That doesn't make sense to us,
right?
Yeah,
but it's the difference between drawing a graph,
which is just a graph and drawing something that's supposed to show something in
space.
He goes on and says,
uh,
it could be that the two chlorine and positions one,
two are in truth more distant from one another than the ones in positions one
for,
and he draws an exclamation point there.
All right.
This just doesn't let her,
it calculates hypothesis making hypotheses about the relative positions of the
atoms in space would make possible two isomers of dye chloro methane,
even accepting the symmetry of the four valence is that is that all the valence
is of a single carbon are equal equal to one another and the existence of a
single isomer of methyl chloride for example.
And he draws the two structures.
Here are the ones where the fluorines are far from one another and when they're
near one another,
but that's just the graph,
right?
That's not where they are in space.
Okay.
There would all he added as an afterthought between the lines here.
There would also result two isomers of ethyl chloride.
All right,
I repeat that.
I don't consider this,
this kind of isomerism absurd,
but since we have no means to know the topographic position to the Adams,
while we have many to know how they are connected to one another,
I consider it a bit dangerous for science shooting off into space in search of
Adam's one risks losing the ground under his feet,
right?
So be careful.
Former student greetings to Cannizzaro and Kerner Amato.
I'll write soon to come piza your friend out awfully but
okay,
so be careful.
This isn't what structures are about right there.
Just graphs that show constitution.
So here's coronary.
You remember before you went south and get with Calculi and on the right of this
group is Albert Loddon Borg who once you know,
once you've read what he wrote,
you can sort of read into his attitude there that he was a hard guy to deal
with.
Okay.
He thought he knew a lot and he didn't know a lot but not as much as he thought.
So he published this paper the next year in 1869 or the same year that that
Paterno published his thing calculate adopts two hypotheses.
One the six hydrogen atoms of benzene or equivalent.
That's what,
uh,
what current or actually proved and to each hydrogen atom of benzene has two
sets of two others which are symmetrically arranged with respect to it.
That is one.
Two is one is the same as one.
Six and one three is the same as one.
Five although for is unique with respect to one.
Okay.
So there are two that are symmetrically arranged already.
Several years ago I had occasion to make calculate aware that is graphical
formula for benzene is not adequate.
Right.
Since here one,
two,
one,
one six must be in equivalent.
While one could have various views about whether positions three and five are
equivalent or not,
why would one and to be certainly in equivalent to two and six that is be
certainly an equivalent but three and five might or might not.
Yeah.
Kate [inaudible]
both have a single and a double.
But what about,
what about one three and one five are they a hundred percent equivalent?
It's a double lines or anything.
Uh Huh.
Cause one is single double and the other is double single going the other way.
So that might or might not be equivalent.
A lot in Borg says both conditions could however be fulfilled through
alternative formulas which so far as I know have not been proposed before.
So here are Loddon Borg's formulas and the one in the middle,
the triangular prism actually came to be called a hundred years later,
or little 70 years later.
Uh,
Loddon Borg,
benzene,
right?
Because someone was able to synthesize that.
It's also called prisma main cause it looks like a prison,
right?
And then there's this funny structure on the right.
Okay.
So this is 1872 and we're going to,
there's van Hoff who is an 18 year old student,
come to bond
to see the great calculi.
And he writes in 1876 at the age of 24,
uh,
reply to Loddon Borg,
proof that the prism formula of Lawton Borg suffers from the same problem as the
hexagon with fixed double bonds.
Removes the previously asserted superiority from the former,
from the prison,
and makes the original calculate notation dot only simpler.
But also the presentation with which the facts conform best cause calculate had
the idea that what these lines really meant was how often the bonds collide,
how often the Adams collide with one another.
They collide more often.
He thought when it's a double bond than when it's a single bond.
So we thought that in this case,
although you would draw a single double single double,
that the number of collisions actually was the same one way or the other.
So you'd draw both formulas to be in between what we would call now residents
formulas.
So anyhow,
this young student,
24 years old now says Loddon borgs off base in saying the prison is better
because it has the same problem and does,
you can't get out of it with his vibration thing.
Okay.
The one,
two,
five,
six,
and three four derivatives are completely similar,
although differing from four or five,
two,
three,
six,
one.
So one,
two,
five,
six and three four are completely similar.
So here's one,
two,
three,
six,
one,
five,
six and three four.
Right?
And you can see that just by rotating by a 120 degrees,
you go from one to the next.
So those who says are completely similar,
although differing from four or five,
two,
three,
six,
one.
Do you see how they differ?
Four or five.
Two,
three,
six.
One,
four,
five,
two,
three,
six,
one.
Now are the red and the blue different or not?
The reds are obviously just rotate.
You get from one to the next.
How about from a red to a blue?
Can you rotate to get from one to the other?
From a red to a blue?
Say the ones in front?
Yeah.
What happens if you rotate to put a red line on a blue line?
So him sitting on a square face,
ah.
Then it's sitting on a square face instead of a triangular face.
It's not the same anymore.
Everybody see that?
Right?
This,
this as drawn.
It has a triangle on top.
If you turn it 180 degrees,
so as the impo super impose the blue in front on the red,
then you no longer have a triangle on top.
It's not the same thing.
Van Hoff 24 years old says,
what do you think Loddon Borg would say about that?
Well,
we'll see,
but then talk goes on.
He says a one three product is different according to whether a or B occupies
position.
One in the right,
there's single double,
double single.
When you go from a to B.
Okay.
Exactly.
The same thing happens in Lauden borgs formula with the prison and adequate
consideration shows that one and two are absolutely different.
So one and notice he puts dashed lines in y.
Why is one bond shown dashed says so,
right?
Because it's behind.
It's hidden.
So he's definitely showing this in three dimensions.
And if it's in three dimensions,
then a B goes left
to write in one and right to left and the other and you can't superimpose them.
They're not the same thing according to van off.
Now what would Loddon Borg say about this?
He wouldn't take it lying down.
He wrote back and said,
Vance Hall found,
finds the two formulas below.
Absolutely different.
How is what he wrote different from what Van Hoff wrote?
How are Loddon borgs formula's different from Vat offs.
It's got a three d.
Pardon me?
It's not,
what is it in three d?
How do you know whether it's in three D or not?
It doesn't use dashboard.
Ah,
he doesn't use the dash line.
Okay,
so he says they're absolutely that bad off fines.
That my absolutely different,
but he's just drawing constitution.
What's linked to what?
Right.
I cannot agree with him in this van took off is dragging something into the
formulas which I together with most chemists expressly exclude.
I refer to the arrangement in space.
Right,
so keep that out.
Okay.
The formula takes account of the composition,
molecular weight and mode of union of the Adams,
so composition and what else,
what others see
constitute composition,
that composition of molecular weight,
he says,
and the mode of union,
right,
which is constitution.
It doesn't talk about arrangement in space.
All right.
Tops,
view of space really will not tolerate the two formulas above to be identical.
Then I invite him for his own special purposes to use a different benzene
formula,
which was proposed by me in the year 1,869 when I compared the hexagon and the
prison for the first time together with the prism to which it for me,
certainly identical.
It is a so called cross of David.
Yeah.
Even van Hoff.
We'll have to find that these two formulas are absolutely identical.
Okay.
Now,
how could the prism be identical?
To this.
There's the prison.
They certainly don't look identical,
but watch this.
Let's twist it,
keep all the bonds,
but twist it.
All right?
So as long as you don't have dashed lines for three D,
they're the same.
One is just twisted.
Okay,
so Lundberg is expressly keeping this out.
Now,
this point of view survived for quite a while here.
Here's some notes taken by a former Yale colleague,
RM Fou us,
uh,
at night in the 1920s when he was a student at Harvard in Kohler's course,
his notes say benzene gives one mono substitution product and three dice
substituted cyclohexyl trying if you had the ring with double single,
double single apparently requires four die substitution products.
So,
uh,
one,
two and one six would be different.
It was argued,
but then he shows another example of a experiment that's been done here with
this molecule.
Now these hydrogens could be it.
It turns out that,
uh,
that those hydrogens will call later Alpha hydrogens because they're the first,
next to a carbonyl group.
So here's a carbon oxygen double bond.
And then to see that has the h carbon oxygen double bond to see that has the h,
those are called Alpha.
And it was known that it's possible to eat,
to easily substitute Alpha carbons with other things more easily than other
carbons,
typically other hydrogens.
So you'd expect to get two possible structures.
You could,
you could do this Alpha one and get the are in that position or this one and get
are in that position.
So you'd get two products,
right?
Those two
we can alkylate that is put the r group on gluconic acid in several ways,
but we always get the same product.
One,
two cannot be made no matter how we go.
Hence it is not surprising that only one Ortho die substituted product for
benzene exists.
The double bonds shift until the stable system is reached,
right?
So you can't make one or if you make it in immediately transforms to the other
ones.
So there could be too,
but there aren't.
Okay.
So this is,
this is what,
this is a 40 years later,
almost half a century later,
and he's still saying the same thing.
Okay.
Now,
uh,
is it really that,
well,
you can calculate by that the minimum energy really is symmetrical with equal
bond distances,
but it vibrates.
It can vibrate like this,
right?
Yeah.
In and out.
And that the frequency of that is 1276 wave numbers.
You've taken spectra,
you've seen that kind of thing.
Although this particular one is not active in the infrared,
you can't see it in the air.
It's called breathing.
Right.
Okay.
But there's another way it can vibrate like this distorted that direction.
Then back to symmetrical and in the other direction,
see what that is.
That's distorting in the calculate direction.
Single double,
single double,
right.
So that,
that one is at 1367 wave numbers.
The calculate distortion,
but it's around a single minimum.
So at any given time,
the thing is probably vibrating.
So it is single,
double single double,
but the lowest energy is all the same.
Intermediate distance.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now,
might you be able to push on benzene and make it favor the calculi structure
with alternating bond distance as well?
That's a challenge.
So,
uh,
a chemist named Jay Segal,
and his colleagues synthesize this one,
which you'll notice has a four membered ring with funny bond angles attached to
one side of the benzene.
That means those angles are going to be stretched and so on.
So they're going to distort and make that bond different.
And indeed that bond one six is a little different.
But on the other side of there,
if it made that one,
let's say it's a little bit long,
make it single in the neighbor's double because of the way it's being stretched,
then if that propagated around the ring,
single,
double,
double single,
double the ones on the left would be different lengths,
but in fact they're the same,
right?
So it does,
it doesn't happen here.
So that's the kind of thing that people sometimes do to test out the limits of
these kinds of theories.
Okay.
So we've seen,
uh,
the position determination and now more about tetrahedral carbon.
And to get there,
we're going to step back just a bit to look at Louie Pastor,
who was a different,
in a different line of business at this time.
Now it's hard to prove that two samples are identical because there could always
be some other tests in which they are.
They appear to be different even though everything you've done so far shows them
the same.
But let's take Carbone as an example.
Here's a,
here's a sample of Carbone,
a bottle of Carbone.
And if I crack it a little bit,
I can smell it.
It has a very nice smell.
Yeah,
let's pass it around here.
Don't spill it.
Obviously
you recognize the odor.
Actually I have another bottle too.
Yeah.
Let's start this one over here.
I'll start it with Catherine.
So just smell that one.
Don't put your nose right down in it.
It's not,
but it's,
it's not that strong.
It's very pleasant.
Actually.
Now this stuff is called Carbone.
Uh,
there's a reason it's called Carbone.
how are you doing Rick?
You're with your grinding.
Can you smell anything on it?
What does it smell like?
[inaudible]
a little like sesame seeds,
but there's another pass it pass it to shy.
Next to you.
Here.
Let him smell
so familiar.
How about anybody?
How about the bottle here coming?
Do you notice it?
Is that a familiar set?
It's spearmint.
Not peppermint,
but your close tie.
How are you doing?
Does it smell like peppermint to you?
Like men.
Okay.
Uh,
how are you doing?
You enjoy,
you're grinding up a different stuff.
You're,
you're grinding dill seed in fact.
Does it smell?
Yes it does.
They said at his seat.
What does it smell like?
Bill seed maybe.
Right,
but co but Carbone comes from that.
This is a familiar scent.
I'm surprised you didn't get it shy.
And did anybody else recognize?
Did you get it Andrew?
No.
How about the bottle that's coming along the back row there?
That little bottle?
Yeah.
Notice it rolling.
It's Rye.
Rye Bread has that.
It's caraway.
Those seeds are caraway and caraway is carve is the Latin root for it.
It's like caraway,
right?
So Carbone the substance we're passing around.
Carbone caraway.
Okay.
Now,
so let's look at the,
I suppose we talked these two bottles and you distilled and found the boiling
point.
Both bottles have two 30 to two 31,
right?
The densities are exactly the same.
Yeah.
The refractive indices for those two bottles,
how much they bend light when it goes through exactly the same.
The infrared spectrum are identical to the extent that any I IRS specter of
identical,
you know from experiment that if you put up more than one sample than in
another,
they don't look the same.
Right.
Did you notice that in lab if something,
if you ground up more stuff in less stuff,
the spectra don't really look the same,
but then you can find there is a peak to peak correspondence.
The intensities are never going to be exactly the same,
but to the extent IRR spectrum could be the same.
These are the same.
If you take their Nmr Spectra,
they're the same.
So they must be the same or is there any property in which they differ?
Any property that those two bottles differ in?
The smell is different.
Now those bottles,
if they're in dark bottles,
right,
to protect them from light.
But if I poured them out there,
they should be coalesced liquids.
But I bet anything they're Brown,
right?
Because they've sat around in a little bit is oxidized.
So it's very difficult with,
with scent because little bits of other things could make them smell a little
different.
Right?
You don't need much stuff for scent of the proper thing.
So it's hard to be confident that this difference that one of them is,
is Rye bread,
caraway,
and the other is spearmint.
It's hard to be sure that that's a difference,
but it turns out there's another property you could measure too.
And that,
and Carol Sierra has that property and I'm going to show it to you.
It's the ability to rotate polarized light.
Now let,
oh,
did I bring,
I forgot to bring my Polaroids.
Uh,
so what I'm going to do is ask a ta to go back to my office and on the table in
my office there,
there's a brown package about that big that has two sheets of Polaroid in it.
There's the key.
Okay.
Yeah,
it's not here.
Sorry.
Uh,
let me think a second.
What we can go on to.
Uh,
there's,
I'll tell you the,
the measure of this,
which is you have light that's polarized.
Have you all dealt with polarized lights?
Probably have polarized sunglasses,
you know,
and you can turn it and see different light reflecting off things.
So have you done that?
Okay.
That's why you have polarized sunglasses cause life that reflects,
doesn't go through the particular direction that's in the sunglasses.
So you get rid of reflected light.
Okay?
So,
uh,
but what you measure is when light,
when light goes through a Polaroid filter,
it's as if it were,
you were shaking a rope and it was going through a picket fence.
It can vibrate one way,
but it can't vibrate the other way.
What vibrates in light?
Yeah.
What is vibrating?
What's light?
We went through this before.
Electromagnetic radiation.
What's vibrating?
The electric field and it set up.
So one of these,
if you have a Polaroid filter gets absorbed and the other one comes through.
Okay,
so light that comes through as vibrating this way.
And if you put another one that's crossed with it like this,
what do you get at the 40?
You see nothing.
Because the first one stops one,
the second one stops,
the other one.
If you turn it like this,
then it goes on through,
okay?
But suppose that you put something in the middle that rotated the plane of
polarization.
So,
so the lights vibrating like this.
Suppose it's going like this,
right?
Suppose by the time it gets to the second filter,
it's like this,
right now you have the second one like this.
What?
What do you see?
Light comes right on through because that's the way it's vibrating.
Now,
if you rotate it,
the plane of polarization,
okay?
That's what rotation means.
Okay?
Now,
uh,
you measure this property of a substance and call it specific rotation,
which is how many degrees it's rotate.
And you have to say what light rotates so that the units of Alpha,
our degrees,
how many degrees it changes per,
uh,
PR for per gram,
per millimeter milliliter.
If you put more stuff in,
then you get a bigger effect,
right?
So it depends on the concentration.
So how many degrees per mole you might say.
Okay,
but then it's per decimeter for cause the longer path you'll go.
If it's rotating,
the further you go,
the further it twists.
So the old style cells were uh oh,
that's not it.
A nice try.
Um,
this is,
this is really embarrassing.
It's an envelope.
Okay.
Did you see it?
Okay,
good.
Uh,
okay,
look,
let me show you the other thing.
Is that going to show you,
okay,
here you actually,
here's,
we'll do,
we'll do a trick.
Here are models of Carbone.
Okay,
now I'm going to give him to you guys
and I want you to compare and see if they're the same.
Stand up and let people see what,
so decide.
Hey,
start maybe at the top with a methyl group.
No,
you,
each of you turn both of you turn and face the thing so they can see.
Now hold us.
Start with a methyl group at top.
It starts with a methyl group.
Now,
Russell,
you describe that and John and uh,
and uh,
and then check and see whether Eric,
you check and see whether your model is the same as,
as a,
as Russell's.
Okay.
Well,
while you're doing that,
I'll go help find the,
the thing.
So tell me when I get back.
[inaudible]
let me at this point.
[inaudible] [inaudible] it's like
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
so is that real?
Is that just a peculiarity of the models or does that relate to molecules?
Okay,
well have a,
if I catch my breath,
these are polarized cheats.
So here you see me
and hear or you don't,
okay,
now let's see a case of rotation.
So here you see crystals.
And I'll put this,
I'll get light coming through and there's Polaroid filter.
And here's another polar I'd filter,
right?
So I turn it 90 degrees and now let me put the crystals in there.
Now,
so there most of it's coming through,
but now watch,
what do you notice?
What's happening?
What's surprising about this?
Obviously they're rotating the plane of polarization,
right?
So that I have to set a different angle in order to stop the light.
But what's special about this set of crystals?
Some are right handed and some are lefthanded,
right?
That's sodium chloride.
That's the stuff that gala sock used,
right?
So this property was discovered of crystals early in the century.
Now how about liquids?
Will liquids do it?
Well,
here's a,
here's glass.
A glass doesn't do anything special,
right?
It's just like the air around it.
But let me pour water in here.
Okay.
And see if water does the trick.
Nothing special.
Right?
So let's try Kero Syrup.
Okay.
It's not quite January,
but it takes a little while.
Yeah,
it's a little bit yellow is sat around a while.
What's happening?
Well,
there's an underlying yellow that biases this,
but we can get different colors.
So different colors of the spectrum are being blocked out.
How can that be okay
for different angles?
Different colors.
So the,
this Kero Syrup is rotating the polarization,
but it's rotating different colors,
different amounts,
right?
So we block off different colors at different angles.
Yeah.
Okay.
So if we're going to make a measurement of the angle,
how much it,
it,
uh,
how much it rotates,
we're going to have to say what color we're talking about.
And that's what the D is.
The D is the color.
There's a so called d line of sodium,
a yellow color,
the yellow streetlights or that color.
Right?
So that's the color that was used because it was easy to generate in the old
times.
And 20 is how many degrees because it's different for different content,
different temperatures.
Okay.
So you could measure the specific rotation of a sample.
Uh,
and if it's in the solvent,
you have to say what solvent it is because it can vary with solvent.
So anyhow,
back to our comparison,
these odors were the same,
but we not might not believe it.
But if we measure the specific rotation,
it's equal and opposite one is plus 62 degrees and the other is minus 62
degrees.
So these things somehow are mirror images of one another.
Now here is what you've already seen.
You can write the structure of Carbone,
either a long hand or shorthand and they're the two models and you correctly
identified a difference between them.
That one has a hydrogen pointing backwards and the other coming out toward you.
And is this difference real?
Of course there were differences in the sausage formulas too,
but those weren't real.
Remember those two compounds turned out to be the same compound.
The question is,
is this difference real?
Are there to carve owns but with different impurities in them so they smelled
different or is there just a or is there just one?
Uh,
pardon me,
vice versa from what I said there.
Okay.
So tartaric acid turns out to be the same thing.
Remember Butts alias coined the name isomer to talk about tartaric acid and
receive make acid,
which both came from the as byproducts of the wine industry and had very,
very different melting points.
So obviously they're are quite different from one another and one of them turns
out to rotate light.
If you'd make an experiment like this,
it rotates light to the right by 13 degrees per gram per milliliter per
decimeter.
Okay.
But the,
but if you heat it,
you get another compound called pyro tartaric acid or sometimes Mizaro tartaric
acid.
Mezzo doesn't mean anything except between,
do you know any,
any cases where mezzo means between Mesopotamia means between the Tigris and the
Euphrates river.
Right.
So it just means in between.
So there was another one in between.
Tartare can receive me.
Casad it's,
it wasn't between and melting point.
It had 140 degrees as a smelting point and it didn't rotate light either.
So there were these three different forms of tartaric acid,
but all were found to have the same constitutional formula,
the same things linked to the carbons.
So here's a problem with the model in terms of isomer numbers.
Okay.
Sometimes too many isomers are predicted like paternos die Bromo ethane.
He had different phases of rotations said those were different.
In fact,
they weren't different.
It was just experimental errors of someone who thought they were different.
So sometimes the model predicts too many isomers,
but often,
or sometimes at least it predicts too few as in the case of maleic and fumaric
acid where you have a double bond,
there are two different substances with different melting points and properties,
uh,
with a lactic acid.
Remember that,
uh,
that Shayla had found lactic acid from milk,
but leiby could found it from,
from,
uh,
meat.
And they,
they were the same.
It was found out about this time by a guy named vizslas say news.
They had the same constitution,
but one rotated to the right and the other rotated to the left.
There was tartaric and received me Casad,
which was even more complicated because there was also mezzo tartaric and also
what's called k came to be called El tartaric acid.
And that was the discovery of Pasta.
So at 1848,
which was another revolutionary time in France of poster,
was 26 years old and was becoming an interdisciplinary scientists,
chemistry,
physics,
crystallography,
all he was studying.
And he wrote a paper called on the relations that can exist among crystal and
form.
So crystallography,
chemical composition,
chemistry,
and the direction of rotation,
rotator re polarization.
That is the stuff we're talking about,
which is physics.
Now remember we talked about myths,
relation,
the ability to measure angles on crystals,
intel distinguished crystals by their angles.
So these are pictures that posture was using to,
uh,
to,
draw of his,
uh,
assaults of tartaric acid in particular,
sodium.
It's a dye acid,
so you can have different cad ions,
sodium ammonium tartrate as this one.
And uh,
there's his picture that he drew of it and he said some new,
mostly you see the faces that are shown in that picture,
but sometimes you can see other little faces,
right?
And you notice that,
that this crystals have symmetry.
They have a horizontal plane of symmetry,
and also a vertical plane of symmetry,
right?
So if you can see one of those edges,
you should see the others that are related by symmetry,
this direction,
symmetry,
and also symmetry this direction.
So you should see all eight,
uh,
in the tartrate,
but always,
only four of them are observed in sodium ammonium tartrate.
Not all eight Mitsa relish.
Had studied this stuff and he was sort of the father of measuring angles like
this.
But when pastor was trying to learn the technique and repeat it,
he noticed that you don't very often get these edges all together,
these little tiny ones.
Usually it looks like the original picture did.
But when those sharp edges or truncated by little additional faces,
you only see four,
you don't see all eight.
So Mitzi,
Alicia had reported that the,
and now how that was tartrate right now they had the idea that Rasamayi,
which remember,
didn't rotate light postures idea was that molecules were twisted in a right
hand or left handed helix and therefore they had this effect on light to make it
twist,
right?
But ones that aren't twisted,
like received make acid where the molecules aren't twisted,
then at least in those you should see all eight because you will have mirror
images.
Okay.
So he thought untwisted molecules would be what's called Hola.
He'd roll that is have all their faces.
So he studied,
uh,
the sodium ammonium morass,
a mate,
and was quite surprised to find that sometimes he saw the red ones.
Sometimes he saw the green ones,
but never on the same crystal.
Some crystals were right red and some were left green.
So he separated those crystals.
The red,
the right ones from the left ones he's,
he wrote,
I carefully separated the right from the left crystals and observing their
dissolution separately with monsieur [inaudible] polarization apparatus.
The thing that measures the rotation I saw with surprise and delight that the
right crystals deviated the plaintiff of polarization to the right and the left
to the left.
So why did receive,
make acid not rotate light?
Cause it was a 50,
50 mixture of things that would rotate at one way.
It's not that it was untwisted,
it was that some of them would rotate it one way and some would rotate at the
other and they'd cancel out.
Okay,
whoops,
I improve this and forgot to take that one out.
Sorry.
Okay.
So now he knows what's going on.
Received make acid is actually a 50,
50 mixture of right handed Dextro tartaric acid d that has a plus rotation and
lefthanded tartaric acid l Livo,
which has a minus rotation,
but the same melting point,
the same rotation,
but opposite in direction.
So those are mirror images of one another now.
And the receiver make acids of 50,
50 mixture.
Now this was 1848.
So that's a long time from where we've gotten to,
right?
That was 10 years before the idea of bonds.
Okay.
So that was resolution,
the separation of a mixture into the two components.
Right?
But what is Mezzo tartaric acid?
Why doesn't it rotate?
So now we go forward 24 years,
the bond and there's van Hoff's studying with Calculi at the age of 20.
Yeah.
So that's a quarter of a century.
That's a long time,
right?
It's longer than you've lived.
So here's Van Hoff.
He had some,
uh,
opinion of himself.
He,
he,
uh,
he won the first Nobel prize.
I mean,
he had a,
a high opinion that was a completely justified,
uh,
he in 19 one,
the first Nobel prize in chemistry.
And he didn't get it for this,
which he should have gotten it for.
He got it for inventing physical chemistry.
The most admired trait he had was imagination.
So he liked poets and artists.
In fact,
his hero was Lord Byron.
Look at that.
Okay.
And in 1874,
as we said,
he was a student and he wrote this,
a pamphlet in Dutch,
which was then translated into German and called the arrangement of atoms in
space.
And it was published in 1877.
It was 53 pages long and heavily illustrated.
And look at the website for this.
One of the Wikis I've assigned does that website.
And also,
uh,
this website about criticism of Van Hoff by of guide named Colby.
So here's Herrmann Colby.
He was twice more than twice.
Van Hoff's age and a pillar of,
of,
of traditional chemistry.
He wrote in a review of this book,
it is completely impossible to criticize this booklet in any detail because the
fancy trifles in it are totally devoid of any factual reality and are completely
incomprehensible to any clear minded researcher.
The brochure begins with the words.
The modern chemical theory has two weak points.
It says nothing either about the relative position of the or the motion of the
atoms within the molecules.
This is absurd,
right?
But he was wrong right now am I like calculate cause I'm more than twice as old
as you are.
Right.
So those are three websites you should read about this.
But in fact it's not true that Vantiff was devoid of any factual reality cause
we've already seen some of his evidence and we'll see more next time.